so you said wisdom is universal yeah
what about wealth and power yeah well uh
well I guess it depends on what you mean
by power so I think of power as the
ability to to influence a large number
of people yeah so
um and this is one of the interesting
things about the fact that cash
economies are so are evolutionarily very
recent and that we're people are like so
so I guess recently or it's about to
happen uh that um Elon Musk is going to
buy a Twitter okay
is it happen already yeah okay so they
said like the the wealthiest or one of
the wealthiest men on Earth has now
purchased the most influential media
platform uh on Earth and so uh obviously
you or I couldn't
um compete with Elon Musk and uh for the
purchase of Twitter and so uh the fact
that cash economies allow how the
stockpiling of unprecedented amounts of
wealth
produces these tremendous power
differentials that that didn't exist in
in over most of human evolutionary
history
so their wealth is power but you can
also be
um the power can be attained through
other ways yeah but but I would say that
the interesting thing about wealth is
that it's an infinitely fungible
resource
so you can use it and translate it into
many many other things like buying a
buying Twitter or
buying a big house or or even getting
mates or an artificial
um in the I don't know if you want to
get into that at all but I need to have
these sex dolls or a virtual virtual
reality sex that some people are are
developing if you have enough resources
you can purchase things like that so you
can trans you can translate wealth into
a variety of other
tangible things in ways that that you
couldn't ancestrally
so that's one really powerful thing but
there is still power that's correlated
but not
integrally connected to wealth which is
like being leaders of Nations like
technically the president of the United
States salary is not very high
right
presidents and and then you look you go
outside of that into the half of the
world that's living under authoritarian
regimes you have dictators
and there's
um those those are very powerful usually
men
uh and
presumably there's some value there in
the meeting selection aspect yeah yeah
absolutely and and it's not by chance
that
um most of them are men
um and this is gonna sound strange or
and hopefully not offensive to people
but
um if you ask the question why are why
is it the case that men are in positions
of power
um so much more so than than women well
in part it can be traced to women's mate
preferences so it's one of the sex
differences that women have over
evolutionary time preferred men who had
power status resources
um
Etc and what that has done is it's
created selection pressure on men to
attach a high motivational priority to
clawing their way up the status
hierarchy
um and and studies of time allocation
distribution show this where men are
they're more willing to sacrifice their
their friends their grandmother their
kin or whatever to claw their way up to
the top of status hierarchies women much
less so women
spend more effort maintaining
relationships with their kin or their
friends their friend networks and so
forth and so
um and and so in a way so you could say
not only are you uh not only are men in
positions of power more than women now
you're blaming women for why they are
and it's not it's not a matter of blame
but I think that that what I just
outlined is is an essential part of the
causal process the co-evolution of
women's mate preferences with men's
motivational priorities